sometimes I wonder if we are all
connected by some kind of
Universal magnetism or vibration that
permeates our being and transmits ideas
and feelings among everybody
I wonder that same thing that's right
and uh the reason is it really does feel
like this ridiculously slow news day
like none of the news is moving me
despite the fact that we've got a new
report that the Biden another member of
the Biden family was receiving cash from
China despite the fact that Poland is
sending fighter jets to Ukraine
dramatically escalating the war causing
World War III to Trend all of this is
happening and everybody kind of feels
like nothing is happening and I'm like
why is that shouldn't we be like holy
crap this whole thing is imploding the
banks are failing or maybe
the bubbles burst right we've been
inundated with too much all at once and
now no one cares at all World War III is
happening the banks are collapping the
Biden family is crooked